in everyday life we have all sorts of
fears and my personal experience with
fear is parachuting I did it several
times and I discovered it's very scary
but then I got interested in how you
overcome fear my line of experiments
deals exactly with it how we overcome
fear how we change fear and the
particular experiment we just published
now in nature is about preventing fear
altogether preventing it from from
returning in this experiment we studied
very simple type of fear learning where
we present you with a neutral stimulus
like a yellow square and we pair it with
a shock after a few pairings your body
elicits a fair response we measure this
by measuring the skin conductance
response okay there was no you can see
the response on the computer that's it's
a very strong response it's really just
the electrical conductivity of your
sweat glands and that's just part of the
natural arousal response you would have
with fear what what we can do though we
can get rid of that fear now just by
presenting the yellow square over and
over and over and get begin and have
nothing bad happen eventually you're
going to learn that the yellow square
doesn't predict shock and I'm not going
to see this fear response in your body
this is called extinction and it works
pretty well it's the basis for
treatments for phobias the problem with
that type of learning is that what we've
done we know this with a lot of
behavioral studies in humans and other
species is we've created two memories
yellow Square predict shock and a second
one yellow square does not predict shock
and the problem is over time those two
memories compete for expression and this
is one of the big challenges and
treating anxiety disorders we can get
people in the clinic
to not be so afraid of things but now
you get them out in a stressful
situation and all of a sudden those
fears come back it's the fact that we
have two memory representations that are
competing it leads this to happen so
what we found in our experiment is that
the way to get around the problem of
fear coming back is to remind the fear
memory before we do extinction training
so to remind the fearful memory we just
present the yellow square again this
brings back the fear then we wait a
little bit and then we start with
extinction training which is presenting
the yellow square again and again this
manipulation keeps the memory
extinguished it prevents the fear memory
from returning so the reason why it
works is because we take advantage of a
phase of memory called reconsolidation
and this is a process that happens
naturally whenever we remember something
a nice way to think about it is like a
file on your computer you have a file at
you a document you wrote and it's stored
then you open it you update you putting
new information then you save it and
store it again so now it's stored in a
new form it doesn't create a new file in
addition to the old file just one file
but now it's updated so what we do is
reactivate the memory it goes into this
phase called record solid Asian which is
basically the restore egde of the memory
if we do extinction training at that
time it doesn't form a new memory this
the information acquired through
extinction is merged into the original
memory and it changes its original
properties so now we have one memory but
stored in a different form and now what
we would expect is the case in that
situation is when we wait a day the fear
doesn't come back when we stress you the
fear doesn't come back and that's
exactly what we found the big difference
between this and what you see in the
Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless line is
here we're targeting we're targeting a
very specific fear
not your ability to recollect
information so in that movie Jim Carrey
wanted to completely forget Kate Kate
Winslet altogether here because this
specific type of fear memory which is
represented in your body's response to a
fearful event we're eliminating the
memory of that you will still be able to
tell me what happened and you will still
you know have all of that information
available because that's another kind of
memory we didn't target and that's a
good thing because if you supposedly
erase memories you don't want to create
blanks in your life that the whole parts
are missing if you still remember the
content you have continued in your life
you just change your emotional response
so the intrusive emotional fear doesn't
interrupt your everyday life whenever
you remember you can remember but it's
not special anymore
so you know at this point how this works
in the clinic is going to be all
speculation but what this data suggests
might happen in the future is if you
come into the clinic with a fear related
disorder like the phobia more PTSD if we
can understand how these memories are
restored when they are retrieved much as
we do in this in this study we and then
may be able to time our therapeutic
interventions in such a way where we
aren't creating new learning is
overriding those earlier memories but
actually rewriting them in a sense if we
can time that correctly so we can target
these mechanisms perhaps we'd have a
more effective long lasting outcome
you